and i feel like oftentimes women
specifically get pigeonholed into one
thing you know if she's if she's tough
and angry then she can't be soft and you
have to kind of choose a side and you
know women were so complicated and it's
um it was really beautiful to be
encouraged to explore
all of those different parts of selena
at one time
[Music]
it's wild it's still it's still wild you
know it's one of those things that you
never i never even considered could
happen and it's rare to be a part of a
film where the making of the film is
just as intense as the coming out as the
of the film so i'm still kind of
in disbelief
i do it was something i was really
really focused on and interested in was
you know these how do i how do i allow
her to be vulnerable and powerful at the
same time
which is oddly a combination of things
that we don't really see a lot and i
feel like oftentimes women specifically
get pigeonholed into one thing you know
if she's if she's tough and angry then
she can't be soft and you have to kind
of choose a side and you know women were
so complicated and and it's um it was
really beautiful to be
um
encouraged to explore all of those
different parts of selena at one time
i don't know how to play a
one-dimensional character i hope but i
do think that oftentimes there's just
those roles just simply aren't written
at all like women are often accessories
to men in film and and storytelling it's
really exciting to have
a true
uh three-dimensional female character in
a male-dominated film and franchise um i
think whenever i overcome something that
scares me and that happens often you
know it happens it can be like just a
moment i can every day there's some
moment that's like oh this is scary can
i do this i'm nervous and i think that's
why we love watching films about
adventure right it's like this idea of
overcoming something and and um you know
stepping into this role was was was
really scary and and now that i've done
that i'm i'm really proud you know all
of those women have
completely made the role themselves
their their own and you know i think
they're the reason i love
catwoman they're the reason i fell in
love with this role to begin with you
know everyone has their own journey i've
struggled myself with you know eating
disorders and pressure to look a certain
way and um you know i've really i've
i've found a really wonderful balance
and in terms of you know putting my my
mental health and my and my body first
and i can't perform if i don't have fuel
and if i don't feel well it was a really
intense time you know on top of playing
uh
you know a role that has a lot of
pressure around it and a very emotional
story
also we shot this film during covid and
you know it was just it was heavy for
everybody we had to go through a lot i
tried to be as healthy as i could in
terms of the physicality of it and
wanting to be in shape and wanting to
feel good but also wanting to um you
know make sure i was being healthy you
know something that i really learned
from from the character that i really
hope to you know keep with me is this
idea of of deserving to take up space
you know i think selena that something
that i found so powerful about her and
and really tried to incorporate into the
way that she speaks and the way into the
way that she moves is her taking her
time and
um really not trying to be anything
smaller than she is and or to try and
you know round her edges for anybody
else you know she really um
she she's she's living life to the
fullest and allowing herself to be all
the things that she is and um
that's something that i think
uh young zoe you know she had that
because when we're young we're not like
so jaded and it's something that this
kind of reminded me of
it's great he's such a wonderful actor
and a really kind person and really
loves what he does and is really
interested in in the psychology of the
people and the characters that he plays
and and to watch him completely
transform into this character it's hard
sometimes when you really know someone
pretty well to forget you know who they
really are and and he would put on the
suit and i would really forget it was
rob and and i think that was that was a
really impressive thing to to do and he
had so many limitations in terms of his
movement and half his face is covered up
and you know all of that and he was
really able to bring so much humanity
and emotion
with all those limitations and that was
something i was really really impressed
by
right now we're in a place where it's
you know it's great that the
conversation's happening and that people
have been made aware but i think it also
can often feel like we're checking boxes
and that doesn't feel good either when
you feel like okay now we have a female
character or a black character or a gay
character or whatever it is and it feels
like we just have to make sure that no
one gets mad at us that's also not the
point of storytelling so i think we're
still in a very awkward transition i saw
michelle pfeiffer soon after i got cast
and that was really
incredible i mean she's just such a
lovely person and was very encouraging
and very warm i haven't seen anne or
halle in person but they have been
really really supportive online and in
interviews and stuff and so i feel very
welcomed into the the catwoman selena
kyle family my turning points
i think it comes back to like
choosing
your truth choosing your own
authenticity over the pressures of the
world you know and it's normal to
to kind of experiment and like go off
your path and try to look like someone
else try to act like someone else trying
to fit into a box that you don't fit
into and i think there's always these
moments in life where you have to choose
you know do i go back to me or do i
transform into something else because i
think the world wants me to be something
else
and um yeah that journey has been you
know i think that's the journey that
we're all on as as women i think beauty
is really about
being yourself i think whenever i see
somebody and or whenever i feel like i'm
being authentic to myself whenever
someone's wearing what they want to wear
and saying what they want to say and you
know however you identify and like being
that i think that's just gorgeous